Okay,
should be live here.
Hello.
Let me set the Twitch title real quick.
The Twitch tag rather.
People have been telling me I should
remember to do this.
All right.
Just flip the screen over
and we will get started properly.
Going to do a
slightly shorter stream today.
Oops. Let me fix I I moved this as well
with the chat here.
Okay. Okay, so to explain where we left
off here, um we got a good oracle
version of the puffer 5 state set
algorithm. It's able to solve 15
increasingly hard so levels in a row
with only completely sparse rewards.
This is a very good result, but it uses
a lot of domain knowledge. We've been
slowly ablating out all of this domain
knowledge and seeing if we can still
solve.
run this real quick.
The main things that are left that use
domain knowledge is we're using the
score and the episode length instead of
advantage or some learning based metric
for the buffers.
And we also have this weird promotion
mechanic
um that resets the buffer every time a
level is completed that needs to go as
well.
That's the current ablation. We'll see
if this works. If this doesn't, I'll
have some thinking to do. If this does
work, we'll have a nice clean slate to
start today. And uh we will essentially
just have to figure out what the metric
is for putting stuff in the buffer.
That's where we are landing for the time
being.
Chat should be good. Yep, we are all
set. Perfect.
score-based promotion frontier state. So
here this is
admission is fine.
Yeah. So, there's a whole bunch of new
Frontierbased stuff. So, the question
will be whether we can get rid of this
or not.
Uh, if we can,
then we essentially just have to figure
out why it is that we need to use
scorebased metric instead of advantage
base metrics.
Seems like it's a little worse so far.
We'll see if it gets stuck or not.
This one is fine if it takes a few more
steps as well, as long as it's within
two billion.
Can we afford to start thinking about
this yet?
I suppose it's also possible that um
most of the remaining domain knowledge
dependence is in this new frontier
metric
which would be interesting. Let's think
about this one first then.
On new frontier,
which is basically just every time you
get to a new level, you clear the state
buffer,
you update the save level, you update
save score.
Mhm. Okay.
Yeah. So, that's quite a bit of domain
knowledge usage right there.
This doesn't look like it would be
particularly helpful. So, if it doesn't
get anywhere near solving without this,
then there's some sort of mismatch here.
It looks like it looks like this is
worse than before,
but we will actually just give this one
a little bit of time.
It went and added a couple things
without
it added a couple silly things. Yeah.
So, this is going to get us to 12 score
but not 15. And then based on the
assault times, you can see how much
worse this is, right? Look at all these
levels you get stuck on for 100 mil plus
steps.
What are you making?
Uh, this is live stream development on
Puffer Lib, which is the highest
performance reinforcement learning
library out there. You can see demos at
puffer.ai.
Uh I am currently just running a bunch
of silly ablations on our latest
algorithm.
Uh we're working on something that
allows agents to improve learning by
directly setting the state of the
simulator to anything that they've seen
previously. And we're trying to do this
in an intelligent way.
Yep. It's all open source. Everything's
linked at puffer.ai.
Uh, so we are writing straight CUDA. Um,
this prototyping is just I'm just doing
this [ __ ] with codeex.
uh code. None of the code that this
thing writes is going to be kept for the
actual implementation. This is just
prototyping.
It ends up being faster and more
numerically stable to prototype like
this in CUDA than it does to go through
Torch.
Like there actually more things that can
go wrong with Torch than there are with
literally codecs writing stuff in CUDA,
which is pretty sad for Torch cuz that's
a very low bar.
Also, even with all this crazy logging
and garbage that I'm doing, we're still
training at 5.6 6 million steps per
second.
What is the automod?
Uh, the auto mod just limit like rate
limits messages.
I have not set any specific automod.
It's just default Twitch or whatever.
So, if you spam too many messages too
quickly, it'll like start dropping them.
Also, anything that it thinks is a link,
Twitch tends to drop.
Okay. Replay buffer reset. Focus on
score advance.
Yes, do star the puffer on GitHub if you
have not already is all open source.
That helps me out a surprising amount.
What I'm essentially trying to figure
out right now is
I'm I'm trying to figure out what
portion of the domain knowledge is the
thing that really matters for this task
to be learned.
So, right now, this is not clearing the
buffer ever. We're not doing anything
special on level advance,
but we're guaranteeing we're only ever
sampling segments that have the current
highest score.
I think this is still a domain knowledge
removal compared to what we had working
previously. So, if this works,
this will still be nice. And then this
will tell us that we don't actually need
to clear the buffer. It's more about the
way that we're sampling from it.
Is this PLR? This is not quite PLR. This
is substantially more advanced than PLR.
Writing a blog on how making basic RLM
taught me more than two years of CS
classes and only three. if you think
about it.
Hey, thank you. I'm glad that this stuff
helps and um I hope you've read my two
big educational articles. Like most of
the stuff that I write on X is a very
very good way to start learning both
basics and current state-of-the-art.
Um I tend to write things that are much
more engineering heavy than math heavy.
And um the engineering is a lot more so
just very very basics but done well. So,
it's quite accessible compared to a lot
of stuff out there and it works very
well. Hello, welcome.
Yeah. So, FBR just um to give you an
idea compared to PLR, PLR requires you
to start um at like the beginning of a
specific level, which also requires that
your environment is made up of levels.
What I'm doing now allows you to rewind
specific trajectory segments.
So, you should be able to set anywhere
in the middle of a level, which is much,
much more powerful,
at least in theory.
Yeah, this is definitely better than
before. We'll see if this full solves.
It should full solve. I think that this
is equivalent to the previous algorithm,
but it's cast in a way that makes it
more general and makes it easier to ask
the next set of questions.
Also, this is going to be a fairly short
stream by my standards today. I think
this is we're probably going to do about
3 hours worth of content.
Like, this is heavy algorithm work. This
is not the type of thing that you rush.
I know that like the programming side of
this is trivial because this is just me
typing crap into codecs, but like the
actual experimentation behind this is
quite heavy.
Um, we stripped out quite a bit of
additional domain knowledge just from
the current version of the algorithm
and we still have it working. We're
testing right now. This would get us
down to essentially just
uh the admission metric to the buffer
and then the sampling scheme which
sounds like a lot but compared to what
we were doing earlier is not that bad
and got zero views.
GitHub is not social media, man. Like,
yeah, get GitHub is not social media.
The things that do well on GitHub are
like tools that people actively use in
their day-to-day or projects that people
are building stuff around.
or just like, "Hey, this is cool. Look
at this." That's more social media.
As long as this doesn't stall here, I
think this is a a good solve.
How much domain specific stuff is left?
um
quite a bit Jess, but it's all sort of
grouped together now into like one or
two core ideas.
I'll go through the latest version after
this. Anish, I actually thought like
pretty early on as soon as Tim submitted
this, I went, "Oh, duh. How did I not
think of this?"
Like this was this is one of the more
predictable useful ends.
I can look at stuff, I guess. Sure. I'm
in the middle of algo dev, though.
Okay, this works.
Okay, it's summarizing this wrong. So,
ignore this. Fresh ends explore normally
on pause terminal positive reward
capture full from entry solve segment
admission is scorebased.
You admit segments to the buffer that
are higher score or lower length.
Segment quality is simple.
Valid positive score or count.
Buffer is not cleared.
Uncore segment unerscore advance
retained buffer stores top segments.
It was master current highest scored
retained segments only. Okay.
How long have I been coding? Since I was
like 14.
15 years.
reward scaling five. Um
maybe Jess. I think we might have to
change the advantage scaling though.
We'll see.
Started in high school. Yeah. I mean, it
depends what you count as seriously
starting cuz I like I did a couple dumb
things even before that.
I guess the first non-completely trivial
things I did were making some Minecraft
mods, which is not a good way to learn
programming because uh Java sucks.
Um, but I got into research very soon
after that. So, research has been what
14 years maybe.
Oh, for being okay, then I can actually
give you some advice if you're that
early on. Hang on.
I I do have an article
um here. Let me just find this article
because I do we actually have a number
of people that contribute to Puffer that
are quite a bit younger.
Yeah, that's the thing. And I can tell
from the docs like
only for their license and read me.
Okay, then you're actually doing
something correct.
If that is true, then you're actually
that is way better.
It's hard to say cuz this is more so
just like an injection tool.
I can tell from the docks that like that
makes sense then.
Um,
this is probably not the type of thing
that you want to be like sticking on
GitHub as like your first couple of
projects, but
Okay. I mean, you're doing something
correct, I'll say, if you're not just
totally vibe coding stuff. Um, I you
have like a seriously wrong view of how
open source works if you expect to like
upload a thing a day or two ago and get
views or whatever. Um,
the best piece of content I have for
people who are, you know, in their first
few years,
this article right here, this has all of
my best advice, particularly if you're
interested in research side stuff.
This saves you a lot of time, and it's
the type of thing where you'll have to
read this several times and like come
back to this once you've been doing
stuff for a little longer to see how
true some of these things are. But if
you really like internalize this, it
will save you a ton of time.
And that is my suggestion. I'll link
I'll link this in chat as well. I mean,
all my articles are there, but that
would be my suggestion.
Why don't you like OP or functional
programming? Because they're both
dogmas.
They're both form over function.
Yeah, Jess. Everybody's done that. When
did I start streaming on Twitch? Uh, I
don't know, two, three years or
something. Form over function.
Like
object-oriented and functional both give
you a very dogmatic, prescriptive way to
do everything.
There are occasions when either of those
approaches are better suited to a very
specific problem. However, in practice,
they're both very, very heavy ways to
program that change how you would have
to write things from the normal just do
it in the shortest way possible. They
change a lot um from what you would do
without having either of those
preconceptions.
And it is very very rare that a specific
topic justifies that big of a change in
how you would approach the problem.
The problem is that if you're introduced
to object-oriented or functional very
early on, they will like whatever you're
introduced to first will feel very
natural,
but it's only because that's what you're
introduced to first.
If you see like just lower level dev
that doesn't have either of these
imposed upon you and gives you a lot
more flexibility and then you see them
later, it's a completely different
story. You'll be like, why is this stuff
so bloated?
This is one of the reasons I don't
suggest learning C first because there's
some like you actually have to
understand to some extent how a computer
works for things to make sense. But I do
recommend learning C quite early after
Python or whatever your first
programming language is. Um
because you really don't understand how
programming works until you know some
systems.
And I hated systems when I was earlier
on because I thought it was just
everything takes forever to build and
everything is super errorheavy. But
that's simply because I was introduced
to it wrong. The truth of the matter is
very often you can take some of the most
complex things out there today,
re-implement them with no dependencies
in C and end up with way less code than
is currently out there, way, way, way
simpler structure and way higher
performance and just general overall
better clarity.
So much so that we did this with Puffer
Lib and we have the now the fastest
reinforcement learning tools in the
world.
Let's not get me too sidetracked though.
We have this experiment finished.
So if this then works with very heavy
prioritization,
then the only thing we need to figure
out is
the score rule.
Okay,
that's cool.
We will try this. If this also works,
then we really only have to deal with
the admission segment.
They make living money now they do. So
Puffer is a company as well. Um all our
software is free and open source. Uh but
we also build high performance
simulations for a variety of different
areas. We do dedicated R&D on different
topics and uh companies can hire us to
do that for them. So we build very fast
RL sims in finance, commerce, uh we've
done animation, defense, gaming, lots of
different areas. We do research around
the same. We integrate everything with
all of our latest tools from Puffer
and we charge a premium for that.
research to be done, but the vast
majority of the discussion is just
[ __ ]
We Okay, here is this.
Why are we stuck
Buffer is sometimes wrong but very
rarely.
discounts are for brokers. as hell.
Uh I mean Puffer is all free and open
source.
I um if you're an academic labs like
academic labs get free like free
priority support especially for open
source stuff
for companies though. No, the prices are
not cheap and um well they're cheap
compared to what we're doing I suppose
at the moment but um they are high and
they keep going up as puffer matures.
I don't believe this. I think it has a
bug in here.
You see,
thanks for working on puffer using it.
Research and sim racing. That's awesome.
If you got any M's you want to open
source, shoot us up a PR.
We're always looking for cool new tasks
to integrate his baselines.
Is an intern. Oh yeah, he's doing a PhD
now, right, Anes?
So, the one thing is for interns. Um,
exception made for Finn because Finn
submitted the drone end was like, okay,
like duh. Um,
oops.
Um, but for the most part, we kind of
need
uh at least anybody that we're hiring
for any like real amount of money needs
to be working on client stuff because
Puffer is bootstrapped. Uh, our funding
comes from doing projects for clients.
So, in order to pay for people,
they sort of need to be directly
contributing to the professional side.
See,
Sam's also an intern.
Sam, wait, Sam is
uh No, we would have taken uh we would
have hired Sam if he wanted one. Um but
he'd already had a different internship.
I mean, Finn, did the the drone end with
Sam? he asked and I can't possibly say
no based on the stuff he's built.
So actually I have to start with him,
talk to him about when he's starting um
soon. They uh they finish late in UK
apparently.
I mean, like Comcast works for now, but
the thing is like they can just decide
to not have things work for a week and
tell you it's on your end when it's not.
So, we're still getting Starlink.
LM agents were the correct choice.
Jeez.
Yeah, that's one of the really bad
things about like
stupid AI height blowing up is people
will just take things that make
absolutely no sense over things that are
obviously reasonable.
Basics has any RL stuff, they're welcome
to come ringing.
I don't know if they do.
I think it's mostly classic control
crit.
summer internship.
I mean, if you want to work with us on
stuff, it's pretty much just the open
source pipeline. um do stuff
demonstrating that you're competent
and then the easiest avail the easiest
thing frankly is to help us find a
client job that you can work on. Um
now you can't just be using the company
name before you have contributions
but for people who are already active
contributors know they can say hey you
know I'm contributing to puffer liib on
this this and this we work on high perf
simulations in a variety of areas would
you be interested so if you find
something like that that's generally the
easiest way to start with uh with puffer
at least if you don't already have an
obvious area of specific expertise. You
know, I've pulled in people before
because they have a really good
background in curriculum or really good
background in like robotic side stuff or
specific projects before.
But without that, it's generally it's
the easiest way to get started
because as soon as you're working on our
professional side stuff, it's
immediately going to be paid obviously.
Um,
but we need people that we know are
actually going to be able to do the
contracts without taking huge amounts of
my time. Obviously, I help.
those can work for self. That's also
[ __ ] [ __ ] Aaron
here.
Actually, we have a thing to retweet on
this.
because ours models are officially
deployed.
So, we have the
highest performance
driving simulator available.
This is used professionally, the collab
with NYU
and actually I think it was just on the
Discord earlier today, right?
Yeah.
Puffers on the road. Deploying first
policy with puffer
Let me see if there's an account for
this.
They write something here. How long do
most contracts take? Depends entirely on
the scope. Jess,
we usually um price things in increments
of like know milestones of a month or
two.
Finance and stocks. Uh there are
multiple finance M but those are
professional [ __ ]
No, I was going to tweet this anyways. I
forgot, but I'm really not in drafting
tweets mood. So, I think this is good.
I'm sure that this did something very
dumb.
This is essentially saying that it only
is solving the first five levels, but it
has solved all 15 levels.
So, that just means that this stupid
thing broke something. No big deal.
We'll figure that out.
How can RL be applied to finance by
building Sims?
a variety that you could build.
And then you just can crank training on
sim. H.
That seems bad to me.
That bad.
I don't know what he's doing sometimes.
Like I'm pretty sure that that is
No, he literally just ported our version
to Majoko.
I don't know why you do that.
It actually is though. Here I can train
it in a second.
Like I This is literally on the [ __ ]
website, right? Like this is not
complicated.
Look, you go to constellation.
All right. And then you click cart pole
and then you just find like the first
solve here. That's pretty much perfect
perf. Like there there's.13 seconds or
if you want 198 it's 1385 seconds,
right?
Pong trains in. I'll tell you exactly
how long Pong trains in.
And you can literally rightclick those
points and like it'll copy the
hyperparameter to your clipboard. So you
can go repro those results.
We'll see if this one works. So far,
this is nice.
You haven't been streaming for a few
days. Internet was out. You can go thank
Comcast for that.
Hey Cash,
what are you doing, man? 3 seconds for
carpole. That's embarrassing.
We almost saw breakout in that amount of
time. Pong is like 04 5 seconds or
whatever
with Moko.
It shouldn't be longer with Majoko if
it's still 18 million steps per second.
Did you rerun sweep for hypers?
Like look, this is literally on the um
here I just was pulling this up on
stream a second ago. Look, you go to
constellation,
you go to pong
43 seconds, go to cart pole.13
seconds.
We are at
91 wood cutting by end of stream.
Is that in that background?
Isn't it warp for dynamics and then like
ray for rendering
Oh, okay. Yeah, cuz you're doing your
thing with pixels.
Pixels will be slow.
Why are saying
why are VCs saying now days?
Um because they're either lying or
[ __ ]
No, it won't.
When you say pixels, do you mean like
three pixels or do you mean like 64x 64
or something? Or 32x 32
cuz you can just go time a single con
flare, right? And you'll see how slow it
is.
We have a PR from Jonah that I still
need to merge for slightly faster cons,
but I have not been able to get a
reasonably performant con at all
via's hardware ray tracing API.
No, no, no. I don't mean generating the
pixels will be slow. I mean that you
have to then go stick the pixels into a
convenet.
I mean, unless you're going to say it's
like a 16x6 render or something and it's
small enough that you're just going to
stick it into a linear encoder,
then that could still be fast, like at
16 x 16 probably.
Anyways, this is Puffer 5 research going
on here. This is go explory state set
based stuff. We have a baseline that
works very very well, but I'm using
hacky domain knowledge on the task and
I'm trying to get it to work with less
and less domain knowledge.
X chat swallowing my messages. Well,
they shouldn't have fired you if they
didn't want that to happen.
I have no idea what the hell's going to
happen with that.
Like presumably the um the cost for any
fixed quality model just goes down over
time.
6x cart pull. What do you mean 6x? Like
six pendulums.
Um, YouTube auto disables that if you
have links there, Discord
Wait, are you saying that five pendulums
is solved?
You can probably solve that. You
probably That's probably more about
being careful with the end of
implementation than anything.
this is a little bit worse, but I think
this is generally okay.
Let's see. Are we stuck?
Okay. So, this is a little bit bad,
right? Because we're on 13 here when we
haven't solved 12.
No, actually, this is fine.
Yeah, this is fine. We'll see if this is
still good.
you don't want to use
you don't want to use the curriculum M
to add more data
because they well at least with the
current algorithm because they can
potentially produce
um they can produce data that's way too
far ahead of where you're currently
learning.
It's because it's almost it's too good
to learn in some sense.
But provided we solve here, I think this
is still okay.
The thing is we have benchmarks like
that, right?
Like we have um randomly generated mazes
up to a certain size. We have Soabon
it's a decent benchmark. I'd agree, but
it's the type of thing where like I'd
expect you have to mostly just be
careful with the uh the end of
implementation, right? Because you can
very easily just make that thing like if
the dynamics just get off a little bit,
like you could have it perfectly still
and it could still be screwed.
No one is doing what you're doing. It
only seems obvious because of all the
problems that we've solved though, man.
Like
there's not a single piece of the
standard RL stack that we've kept. Not a
single piece.
Rating engine automatically optimizes
kernels. I don't particularly care about
that to be honest.
What do I like about the minimal phone?
Uh, that I can't watch YouTube on it.
I don't really watch a ton of technical
content, Jess. I'm going to be honest.
Robin decided to get employed.
Oh, that sucks.
Okay. Um, let me grab a drink. Let me
take a couple minutes real quick here.
And then what we're going to do is we're
going to continue on. Let's see. I've
been live for Okay, so we'll do like
another hour 40ish. Um, for the stream,
we pretty much have it down to where
there's really one core thing that we're
relying on for domain knowledge, which
is score plus ep length instead of
advantage or something. So, I think that
this is like a pretty clean slate to
start from now. So, um, oh yeah, for
folks who are new around here, I'm just
going I'll be back in like two minutes
or whatever, but
if you haven't already started the
puffer on GitHub, start the puffer helps
us out a ton.
I'll be right back.
Where is There we go.
You got five pendulums.
Nice.
Yeah. I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like, yeah, puffer just solves 10
pendulums
or whatever.
I just want to make sure we have this
version timestamped nicely.
I'm just being very meticulous here with
this. I think
the key thing is just using score plus
length
versus advantage, right?
4 plus appl length.
This is the key thing to figure out.
I want to make sure there's nothing else
though that I'm forgetting, right? Like
nothing else major.
opinion on anthropic nuts.
Buffer be good at card games.
So there's there's this key thing here
which is this frontier
difference.
So it's not just using score versus
using advantage. It's this idea of this
like highest quality thing.
Look at all the stuff that I've gotten
rid of, though. You see all this stuff?
These were all things that I had in at
some point that we got rid of.
use claude. No,
but it's really it's not that deep. I
got sick of giving anthropic money.
Like that's it. It's not that fancy.
It's not that complicated.
Yeah. So, it's this frontier label idea,
which is tough, isn't it?
We're relying heavily on
on this idea of having a frontier.
And then we have the specific score
metrics, right?
We could try other metrics
while keeping this frontier,
but that's not really going to help us.
I'm trying to think what we would do.
I don't know, dude. I like you're
splitting hairs.
The labs are just going to leaprog each
other every couple of months like
they've been doing for the last two
years.
I'm trying to think how we get around
this idea of having to record a max
frontier,
See, it's very funny that it thinks that
this is a replacement. This is like the
models are clearly [ __ ] dumb.
This is still completely domain
specific.
You're just tricking yourself into
thinking that it's general because you
replaced it with like more uristics.
Bro, you got to spend less time on X or
like reading random crap news.
I'm trying to think how we get rid of
this idea of the frontier.
Actually, if we think about it,
this entire thing, it's just aimed at
it's just aimed at preventing you from
training on stuff that's too far ahead,
right? So, it's like if you get a lucky
segment that's like right ahead of what
you're learning now, that's good. But if
you get very lucky and go very far
ahead, then it's not.
I think that's the key.
See, the thing is that I think that I
think that we basically have these two
things co-designed.
Like I think we have this one hack
because we have the other hack.
If this works, we'll be in a very nice
spot. If it doesn't, that's kind of
expected.
Welcome, Finn. How's it going?
I'd say we've removed 2/3 of the domain
knowledge dependence of curriculum
learning. We have one/3 left to go.
So, we're getting close to um I think
we're getting close to a usable method.
It depends how hard this last third is
to get rid of.
It actually will be very interesting if
this ends up being the correct thing.
getting a bit honest. Those words don't
go in the same sentence.
Is this train running on a single? Yep.
Single GPU, just a single 5090.
It's not really the type of thing that
would benefit much from um massively
scaling batch.
So, this is kind of the optimal setup
for uh research.
There's not really much way for me to
increase the speed of this loop.
Other I guess I could maybe make it
twice as fast if I really like cut out a
bunch of the diagnostics and things.
We're fine for now.
If this solves, this is actually very
useful information.
who can't afford these agentic models
do.
Well, for learning, you're not really
missing out. No.
Um,
and what like the subs are the base subs
are like 20 bucks a month
and this this one here is a hundred
bucks a month. It's not crazy,
but like you don't need these for
learning really at all.
In fact, you be you will be much better
off learning without these stupid
things.
Like, read my guide. Go follow some of
the stuff in there. You'll be better off
for it.
Do you want a patch which will allow it
to access to GPU will allow it to run?
It can do that anyways. And no,
then it's just going to be piping the
logs to itself constantly. And the way
that I do the logs, it's just going to
spam itself with data that doesn't
benefit me in any way.
Why do you think score is better than
advantage for admitting segments? It's
domain specific for sure, Sinn. And I
don't think it necessarily is. Like this
here is this is with advantage.
Um and this is doing well so far. So I
actually think we'll see if this gets to
15 or not,
but it seems very likely
that um it actually wasn't the need for
score as a metric.
I think the key thing is to prevent
is to prevent the model from getting
ahead of itself essentially.
I think what's happening is like
let's say it's solving level three and
it gets a lucky level four solve. It'll
fill up the buffer with later levels
that it's not ready for.
It just barely gets there, But it does
get there.
I'm happy with this result.
I mean, that's [ __ ] great. I didn't
expect it to work that well.
You can see here that the latching it's
taking a little longer. So, there's
definitely room for improvement, but it
does work.
Right. So,
if you think about it, that makes sense
because any lucky solve you get is going
to trigger a big advantage spike.
Well, this is nice. Now, we can kind of
just sit here and think about this for a
little bit.
What metric are you trying to test here?
I can give a quick overview of what I'm
doing here at the moment. So,
this is 15 levels of Soabon
um where they have to be solved in a row
starting from the easiest one up to the
hardest one. If you fail to solve any
individual level within a fixed time
budget, you're reset all the way to the
beginning. We're using this as a test
for the new algorithm which is based on
state sets. So, setting the state of the
simulator to a previously seen state.
What I've done at this point is I've
created a version of the state setting
algorithm that works, but it exploits
some domain knowledge that is specific
to this problem.
I first had a version of this that
worked, but it exploited a ton of domain
knowledge. And I've sort of just been
scraping off little bits of domain
knowledge and still like making
adjustments to keep it general and make
it still work until we get to a general
version of the algorithm that still
works.
Right now the algorithm is down to
essentially you allocate some fraction
of environments to run these state set
versions. Um
environments can save states based on
their advantage. When you save a state
you save the entire trajectory segment
and you sample from those states uh
based on a very heavy priority function.
And then the one thing that is still
domain specific
is we're using the score of the
environment
uh in order to prevent you from
recording
uh prevent you from like recording
states that are too far advanced.
That's the one thing that's still domain
specific.
I will get a cleaner description of this
once I ablate this thing out. There's
still a couple variables I'm trying to
sort through in my head.
Reachability.
The problem, Finn, is that reachability
is very expensive to compute
and it's also domain specific.
You cannot run anything on GPU
unless you patch the support in.
I think it can,
but it doesn't matter either way.
Like that's irrelevant.
I don't need this thing to do my
research for me. I just need this thing
to like [ __ ] out some really crappy
prototype CUDA.
Heck, most of this isn't even CUDA. Most
of it's just a
The key thing here is that frontier.
I'm trying to think how we
It's not exactly similar. Liberty. That
one has way too much human pattern
recognition.
That one is really not an that's not
really an RL challenge. It's like a hard
pattern recognition challenge with a
really easy RL problem attached to it.
And the large models are just so bad at
that that that's where they fail.
We want to keep trajectories with high
advantage.
That's the basic idea of it. But it
turns out that that core idea, that core
idea is correct. But the implementation
of it, there are some things you have to
address for it to work.
Yeah. The like that is the general idea,
but if you go implement that, you will
see like there are some issues with it.
It's a very good idea.
Um,
but there's some things you have to
patch.
That's what we're working on.
Okay. So, we basically have no levels
beyond the previous one in the buffer at
all. That's the key.
So I think that the issue here, right,
is that advantage does not imply
learnability.
But let me can I sort of here why don't
we draw something for you guys? Let me
explain the problem that we have. Okay.
Yes. Okay, cool. So, here's the problem.
You have like Soabon level one where you
have, you know, whatever.
Um, you know, how do we we do like this
and you know, there's your box
target, right? Let's say this one
solved. So this is level one is solved.
Then let's say we have level two,
which is a little harder. You know, you
got like your box here, you got your X
there, but you have another box that's
like here, and then there's an X like
there, and there's a wall
here, or whatever. You can't actually
solve this one, but you get the point.
And this one you don't solve.
And then there's a third level.
Got like three boxes
and then this one you can't solve.
Okay.
So let's say you're solving this one
consistently. Yeah.
Then you get a single lucky solve here.
So you get one lucky solve here.
And then you get one lucky solve on
level three.
Okay.
So in your state buffer,
let's say you have you have some states
and then this thing we fill some states
in here,
right?
But then we get this solve and then this
is going to overwrite this buffer. They
go into here.
because this has high advantage.
But the problem is even if the policy
learns this level three, it actually
hasn't learned level two yet.
So it's basically it can get ahead of
itself.
advantage is not a great level of
learnability.
We essentially just need a measure a
better measure of learnability.
Reachability is not
particularly good.
That's a tough problem. Yeah, it is.
Advantage is not learnability. Advantage
is surprise over reward.
U minus V.
Uh
I think it's
It's the error in the value function.
it's the error in the value function.
Hang on, let me think what that actually
is.
That might be Q minus V. I don't know if
our formulation's action condition
though.
What am I doing? We're trying to figure
out this new algorithm.
In particular, we need to find
We'd like something that is closer to
learnability or reachability than
advantages and that we can compute
easily.
How can someone learn from scratch? I
have a lot of educational material on um
on X X.com/juarez
my articles tab there especially the ML
guide and the RL guide.
I mean, we're pretty much down to like
the last big problem, I think, with the
algorithm, though,
You can have very high advantage on a
state where you just get very lucky
even if it's not remotely learnable.
Which is why you end up with like
learning progress base metrics.
Can I get your LinkedIn? I don't
actually have a LinkedIn that I use.
All the professional stuff is done via X
and email.
This is where I mostly just stream um
stream my research, stream engineering
and the like.
Visit Stanford.
Nice campus.
I'm trying to think if there's something
that I can genuinely do here with it.
How did you get into MIT? I'd been doing
research for a very like I my whole life
was already revolving around research
before PhD for many years
or G AE it is this that is what it
that's what advantage is man generalized
advantage estimate so that's what we're
using at the moment and that's the thing
that's not good enough
because advantage will be very high even
in a state that's very very far away
from where you can currently get too.
I mean, we could just bias this thing
heavily by time, I suppose.
It doesn't feel super great, though.
How's research going? research is going
well.
I mean, we're very close to I think this
is going to be the god algorithm if we
can do it perfectly correctly. Frankly,
it's just tough.
Uh yeah, definitely Stanford area is
much nicer.
Is there a way that we can bias this
thing
in a way that's general and productive?
Like I'm thinking if we do like rolling
mean of segment
That pretty easily penalizes longer
segments, right?
Okay, hang on. How would you implement
this?
If you have the entire trajectories,
would this be easy?
It's a pretty heavy bias, isn't it?
Yeah. I don't super like that.
Wait, no. It's not a super bad bias
though because it's
it encourages you to learn easy easy
stuff first because it's not score
based, it's advantage based.
Okay, there's some version of this I'm
thinking that might make sense.
It's a tough problem
coming up with a general version of the
state set algorithm.
There are a few things that we're
assuming that we need to get rid of
here.
length is not a great
I mean length is also a heristic on this
isn't it
but losing an exploration it's about
essentially
so because you're able to return
directly to rare states
if you happen to get a rare state that's
too far ahead of where the policy is
now.
Like the easy one is you have three
levels. You know how to do level one.
You don't know how to do level two or
level three. If you get a lucky solve
into level two, that's great because
then you can use this data to train the
policy to do level two. But if you
happen to do level two and level three
and now you're just using the training
data from level three without learning
level two in the middle, that's not
useful.
I'm trying to come up with a way of this
with really without using domain
knowledge on this.
I mean, the best thing I can come up
with is a length bias off the top of my
head, right, towards shorter solves. And
that does work. We know that works.
Maybe there's a general version of that
that makes sense.
the parameters. That's the goal crit. We
have a few little pieces of domain
information baked into the algorithm now
and we're trying to do it without them.
Pretty much this the main thing that we
need right now is a method to prevent
the environ like prevent the learning
from getting ahead of itself. Prevent
the policy from getting ahead of itself.
That's the main thing.
Do you see what I'm trying to do,
though?
increase. No. So, advantage increase is
always good. The problem is
learnability,
right? If you're in a very if you're in
a state that's very hard to get to and
you learn how to do that part of the
problem,
that's a good thing, but it's not
actually going to help because you can't
get to that part of the problem reliably
or at All
I mean, I'm seeing it, right?
It's just um
what I've essentially done is I've
encoded a bias, right? Cuz it's going to
take like some steps like one, two,
three
to get there. And then
So, we encode a bias toward shorter
segments by dividing by the length it
takes. So, I'm not doing that exactly
how I'd like to be.
We're 12 in one bill
with one sample from 13
Yep.
This 100 mil. Very nice.
can't max K
if it's large or like you want a short
prefix just
so a short prefix means that it only
takes it doesn't take many steps to get
to a high advantage spike
which has very high correlation with
learnability We don't have a direct
measure of learnability but that should
have very high correlation.
the value function. Having like a
confidence or something would fix this
without a college degree.
Uh, Alec Radford, right?
distributional RL where value function
is. Yeah. So that's kind of what I was
thinking about.
Um
you you need a certainty to it.
I don't know if just bucketing it is
good enough. Maybe it is.
value function confidence I think would
do it because what we could do is we
could do like advantage divided by
confidence up to that point
like sum of advantage divided by sum of
confidence
Olanthropic I don't know enough about
Ola though I know mostly his
interpretability stuff.
It's not really that distributional
changes the framework too much.
I mean, we could do that if we could
come up with a nice way to do it.
Let's see if this works.
Yeah, I uh I saw that. They told me that
up front earlier.
I generally think that Anthropic is like
a very weird outofouch company.
Like the people that work there live in
their own little world for the most part
courses. I can take
my educational stuff is on X.
All my best advice is in my articles
there.
Which big lab is your favorite
buffer.
As funny as it is, we do genuinely have
like the
soda um soda for small model RL
and by quite a wide margin. H.
This is actually a pretty solid result
for this. Okay,
if we can get this to work without the
gating mechanism,
I think I'm mostly happy with it because
I know that
this even though this is a huristic,
it's a pretty good one and it's one that
we could improve
um with other changes to the rest of the
algorithm.
This looks good.
This is 1.2 2 billion with
it probably solves 1.5 bill maybe. Well,
I guess it depends when we actually get
this lucky solve here.
Well, this is fewer steps,
less domain info.
I mean, the real question is whether we
can take out the gating mechanism still.
No, I'm not using cursor. [ __ ] that.
is implemented.
Uh Jess, that would be the robo code end
that Spencer is working on.
He's likely busy with client work last
few days, but um like that is the end
that you use for this.
Yeah, it's just it's doing [ __ ]
We'll run this, but it's doing [ __ ]
Uh they actually had a really good
interview process back then.
Was a much smaller company.
I think that's the only place I've ever
been that had an interview process that
was not just completely stupid.
Hillia was awesome.
Probably one of the people I have the
most respect for in the world.
The guy had like a real presence to him.
It like
he spoke very slowly.
He didn't say much, but he spoke very,
very thoughtfully.
He had a lot of intent.
I remember he asked me um what I thought
about compression as a general like path
to general intelligence. And I said I
said I think it was going to be very
important, but I didn't think it was
going to be enough on its own and that
you were still going to need like
you still need interactivity
essentially.
Yeah, that's true.
Was
it Russian or
said he was Israeli, but I don't
actually remember.
I was pretty sure of that.
Okay, we're at 12 and one bill. Yeah,
Israeli. Okay. See, I remember that
correctly.
I remember he he said he considered
himself to be 100% Israeli. That's why I
was like, is he Russian? No. Right.
Yeah. Why are we not Oh, this is just
bad luck here. You see that? We haven't
gotten a uh a 15 solve. So, this is
where you have to realize like there's
just a lot of randomness.
If we get this soon and it doesn't
latch, then I'll get suspicious.
there.
So, if this number goes to like 200,
then I'll be concerned.
Yeah. So, that one took quite a while,
but we got unlucky for several hundred
million steps on um
on the like the initial 15 solve. His
numbers are actually all quite good.
Wait, why are people liking this all of
a sudden?
Why are people liking this?
This was like the random last summer cut
article. Oh,
Eagle bull something. The something
something
Can anybody figure out how to translate
this page? This actually is kind of
relevant for us.
Interesting. We'll save this. That's
cool.
The main thing I was looking for is
whether it's a a bug or not.
It seems there is some sort of
justification. Whether or not
empirically it makes a difference, who
knows?
see if this still works.
We're almost to 3 hours here as well.
Let me go check on one thing real quick
while this trains.
Okay,
we're good. Do 15 more minutes on this
and I'm calling it. Doing short stream
day.
Oh, this crashes the hell out of Perf.
Interesting.
I'll push it. Yeah, Jess. I'll push the
lightest stable one.
Why are you so interested in Muan?
Um because we use it in Puffer and it
was a generational leap over anything
previous.
H.
That's very cool.
It's doing kind of stupid things here.
We'll see if this works. I very
intentionally said not to do this and it
just did this anyways.
So, um, models are dumb.
Is this the same Genesis as the scam
physics library?
Nope. Doesn't work. Cool.
Uh, seeing
last thing I'm going to try today will
be this.
And then this is good progress for
today. You know, we got rid of a lot of
the domain specifics. There's still a
few bits. We got to run a couple more
experiments real quick and we'll be
done. in a few.
might be better.
Broken puffer model is
better than 20% of the competition.
That's fun.
Hey, Puffer's pretty good.
Buffer is pretty good.
We do like the puffer. Huh?
This will be a very nice place to leave
it.
Yep. Solved with one/3 domain knowledge
in se in 50 mil steps.
Solved with one/3
domain knowledge.
Uh, it's going to be the 5.0 CLX branch,
Jess.
All right.
Cool.
So, for folks who've been watching,
thank you very much for uh tuning in. I
stream pretty much all of my research.
This is now one-third of the domain
knowledge left. It'll be tough to get
rid of. Uh, we're going to have to think
about some stuff, but we're getting
there.
If you're interested in following my
stuff more generally, would you like to
just help me out for absolutely free?
Star Puffer on GitHub really does help.
Join Discord if you want to get involved
with the research like many of the
people you see in the chat here. And uh,
follow me on X for more reinforcement
learning content. Tomorrow is Thursday.
Yeah, I should be streaming tomorrow,
Jess. I don't see any reason why I
wouldn't. Thank you all.